le neuron qui est propriété de quebecor
a des dizaines et des dizaines de
contrats avec le gouvernement à hauteur
de 14 millions des contrats
informatiques
est ce que cette compagnie de brosser
c'est d'avoir du contrat avec le
gouvernement si monsieur péladeau est
bon alors c'est une question pertinente
les contrats qui sont donnés aux
gouvernements sont donnés en vertu d'une
loi de l'administration financière qui
prévoit des règles qui encadrent
l'octroi de ces contrats c'est un
processus administratif
ce n'est jamais jamais une décision
politique ça ne vient jamais au niveau
du gouvernement
il ya donc une loi qui encadre le tout
il ya des règles et ces règles qui
doivent s'appliquer peu importe les
entreprises qui appliquent au
gouvernement sur de tels contrats